so i think this is a good place to talk
about smart contracts then can you tell
me the history of smart contracts
and the basic sort of definitions of
what is it
sure so i i think smart contracts as a
definition has actually gone through
some through some kind of changes or
small evolution
initially i think it was actually a
conception of a digital agreement
that was tamper-proof and could know
things about the world right so it could
get proof
and it could define that something
happened and it could conclude
an outcome and release payment or do
something else that's actually the
definition of smart contracts
that i began working in this industry
with seven or eight years ago when i
started making smart contracts
that is the conception that i had of a
smart contract
then what happened was that was really
hard to do right
building that type of tamper-proof
digital agreement that could also know
things about the real world
and release payments back to people
about those events that were codified in
this tamper-proof format
was actually a very tall order turns out
it's consistent of three parts it's
consisting of the contract
the proof about what happened and you
know the release of value
the way things have evolved so far is
that
the definition has now come to mean on
chain code
right so it's come to mean the
codification
of contractual agreement on a blockchain
right so there's some code of somewhere
on some blockchain
that defines what the agreement is
now that eliminates the part of the
definition that's related to knowing
things about the world
and it partly eliminates the definition
about payments and and stuff like that
but basically it's it's on chain code
right we in in in our recent work on
on the second white paper have actually
put out a different definition that we
call hybrid smart contracts
that actually tries to go back to the
initial definition that i started with
seven or eight years ago which basically
says
that there's some proof somewhere that's
proven to the contract and the contract
can know that
and the contract can gain proof then it
can use that proof to settle
the agreement that's codified on a
blockchain
so you you both need a mechanism to
provide proof you need a mechanism
to codify the contract in a tamper proof
way on something like a blockchain
and then as with all contracts there's a
presumption that there's some kind of
release of value
so i think a smart contract in our
industry right
now means on chain code which limits it
to whatever can be done on chain only
and then in in our internal definition
for us
and for us at chain link and for me um
it's hybrid smart contracts
which is actually the original
definition it's the it's the idea that a
contract
can both know what happened and
automatically
resolve to to the proper outcome based
on what happened
so you're referring to the chain link
2.0 white paper which is
uh paper that i recommend people look
it's a very easy read and very well
structured and very thorough so i really
enjoyed it
very recently released i guess can you
dig in deeper what is a hybrid
smart contract you mentioned sort of
this idea of data
or knowing about the world and
on chain and off chain so what are the
different roles in this so hybrid by the
way refers to
the fact that it's on chain and off
chain contracts
so maybe digging deeper of what the heck
is it and what does it mean to know
stuff about the world from like how do
you actually achieve that
yeah absolutely so the on-chain part
is where the agreement itself is
that's the smart contract itself and
that's where you codify
certain conditions such as the
conditions under which an interest
payment is made or the conditions under
which the the contract pays out the full
amount that it holds
to someone based on a derivative outcome
or something like that
now what the on chain code is very good
at is creating transparency about what
the core conditions of the contract are
it's very good at taking in money from
other private keys that send it
tokens and send it value to hold and
then it's also very good
at returning money or returning value
back to other
addresses or other private keys it can
also be involved in governance it can be
involved in a few other private key
signature based
operations but primarily the on-chain
part of a hybrid smart contract
from what i've seen so far defines the
agreement
takes in value and returns value uh
based upon the conditions codified in
the agreement on a blockchain
the second and equally important
off-chain part
is where the term oracle and an oracle
comes in or an oracle mechanism or a
decentralized oracle network
as we describe it in the paper and this
is another
decentralized computational system
that has a different goal right so
blockchains
have the goal of packaging transactions
into blocks
and connecting them in a
cryptographically unique way to create
security and assurance about
that chain of transactions oracles and
decentralized oracle
networks achieve um consensus and they
achieve
decentralization about the topic of what
happened
right so blockchains structure
transactions some of those transactions
might be the state changes
in different pieces of on-chain code and
then those on-chain pieces of code
require
input i think the thing that people get
kind of a little bit thrown by
is despite being called smart contracts
the on-chain code on a blockchain cannot
actually
speak to any other system so blockchains
are valuable and useful as far as
they're tamper-proof and secure
and to be tamper-proof and secure
they're made this kind of walled garden
that is able to know and interact only
with the highly reliable information
that's within that system which is
basically
tokens and private key signatures
all the other world's information is not
available in a blockchain
inherently and a smart contract or a
piece of on-chain code can't just say
hey i'm going to go get some data from
over here because the api they would get
it from
creates a whole bunch of security
concerns for the blockchain itself
and a whole bunch of consensus issues
about how to agree on what that api said
or what the truth of the world is right
because it's not even agreeing
on what one api said it's more so
creating a reliable form of
decentralized computation
that can give you a definitive proof of
what happened and not just what one api
said so for example some of our most
widely used networks
have well over 30 nodes and well over 10
data sources that are all providing
information about the same type of data
and then there's consensus on that one
piece of data
which is then written in and essentially
given back into the on-chain code
to tell it what happened because you
can't really make an agreement
unless you know what happened right if
you and me were to make an agreement and
set some contractual conditions
but our agreement could never know what
happened it would be completely you know
useless
however if you and we made an agreement
and there was another system called an
oracle mechanism or decentralized oracle
network that proved what happened
definitively and you and me pre-agreed
that whatever this mechanism says is
what happened
then we can achieve an entirely new
level of automation
right we can suddenly say there's this
piece of unchained code that's highly
reliable
we can give it millions billions
eventually trillions of dollars in value
and it is controlled by this other
system over here that's also highly
reliable
under this configurable set of
definitive truth and decentralization
conditions which we all agree
are sufficiently stringent to control
that much value
and therefore the combination of this
tamper-proof on-chain representation of
a contract
and this uh mutually agreed upon
definition
of a trigger or a proof system
combined is a hybrid smart contract
which as you can see
probably already does a lot more than
just a contract on chain
right can you talk about this consensus
mechanism which by the way is just
fascinating so there is the on-chain
consensus mechanism of proof of work and
proof of stake
and then there is this oracle network
consensus mechanism of
what is true so how do you
can you compare the two like how do you
achieve that kind of consensus how do
you achieve security
in integrating data about the world
in a way that's definitively true
in a way that is usefully true such that
we can rely on it in making
major agreements that as you said
involve billions of
trillions of dollars right so this is
the challenging this is the challenging
question right this is the challenging
um problem that oracle networks
oracles we at chain link that that we
work on
in order to create this definitive truth
to trigger
and create hyper automation in this um
more advanced form
more advanced form of hybrid smart
contracts the the reality i think
of this problem is that it is very
specific to
each use case and it and this is
actually how we've architected our
system is in a very flexible way
so so for example um you need an ability
for an oracle network to grow in the
amount of nodes that it has
relative to the value it secures right
so if you have an oracle network
that secures a hundred thousand dollars
in like a beta of a financial product
maybe it can be fine with owens only
seven nodes and only two or three data
sources
right because the risk to that to that
oracle network is relatively low based
on the value it secures
so the first question is actually how
do you scale security relative to value
secured by that oracle network because
it wouldn't be very efficient to have
a thousand nodes securing a hundred
thousand dollars
worth worth of value so one of the first
questions is
how do we properly scale and how do we
compose ensembles of nodes
in a decentralized way where we can know
that okay we're going from seven nodes
in a network to 15 to 31 to 57
to 105 to you know a thousand right
so that's that's one dimension of the
problem so you have to be scaling the
number of nodes relative to the value
that's
that's derived from the truth
integrated into those nodes well that's
not the only problem right the the other
side of this is that you're trying to
create
a deterministic result a deterministic
output
from a set of non-deterministic
disparate systems data sources
or places that prove things can you also
just as a
side what is an oracle node what is the
role of an oracle node
sure so an an oracle node essentially
exists in both places it exists in both
worlds
it exists as an on-chain contract that
represents
either an oracle network or an oracle
node so there's an on-chain interface in
the form of a contract that says
i i exist to give you this list of
inputs
you can request weather data from me you
can request price data from me
you can ask me to send a payment
somewhere like an api so it's a pointer
to uh
api that uh about that that provides
truth about this world
it's an interface so just like an api is
an interface for web 2.0 engineers
oracle networks and the contracts that
represent
them or individual nodes are the
interface
of web 3.0 use of services
and services includes all services
data payment systems messaging systems
whatever web 2.0 or any
kind of computing service that you can
conceptualize
needs an interface on chain in the form
of a contract that says
here are the services i can provide for
you here are the transactions you need
to send me
to get back this data or that
computation or this result
and then what you actually see is that
the centralized oracle networks because
they're uniquely capable of generating
their own computations in a
decentralized way around the data that
they have access to
you actually see the centralized oracle
networks generating a lot of these
services so for example
we have a randomness service a
verifiable randomness
function service that basically provides
randomness on chain
and that randomness is then used in
lotteries and various other contracts
that need randomness
but that randomness that's not a piece
of data that comes from somewhere else
we don't go to another
data source and get it we generate it
within an oracle node
that then provides it over into oracle
node or oracle nodes that provide it
into the contracts
themselves so why do you say oracle
nodes are non-deterministic
well they they are as far as they come
to consensus but they're but
see there's there's this kind of
different problem here right the
blockchains are very focused on
generating blocks of transactions within
a
smaller universe of transaction types a
certain block size and a certain set of
conditions
and and then they have a economic system
that says
you i will perpetually generate blocks
of this size
with these transaction types in in this
kind of limited set of
transaction types whether those are utxo
transactions or scripted
uh solidity or whatever it is oracles
and oracle networks they're um
we don't have a blockchain for example
there is no chain link blockchain our
our
our goal is not to generate a certain
set of
very clearly predetermined transaction
types
into a set of transactions that are put
into blocks and will infinitely be you
know done that way
our goal is actually to create um what
we call a meta layer
a decentralized made a layer between the
non-deterministic
highly um unreliable world and the
highly hyper reliable world of
blockchains
so that the unreliable world can be
passed through this decentralized meta
layer
and it can co-exist with the with the
reliable chain
unchained world exactly it can coexist
and in some cases the metal layer might
generate it
so that the problem in giving you this
straight answer is that there's just
such a wide array of services
right right if you were to say well
sergey how how do we
generate randomness from a data source
well we don't use a data source to
generate the randomness
that's the type of service that can be
generated in an oracle network itself
and so there will be certain
computations that oracle networks
themselves
generate themselves to augment and
improve blockchains
and it is actually the goal of oracle's
to consistently do that so if you were
to think about
the stack in a very generic high level
you would see
blockchains or databases they're
basically the data structures that
retain
a lot of information in this transparent
highly reliable form
smart contract code is the application
logic
it is it is the logic under which all of
this kind of activity occurs
um you know storing data in the in the
data structure in the in the blockchain
as as a database in in in a certain
conceptualization of it
and then oracles and oracle networks
are all the services that are used by
the application code
so you know by analogy let's take uber
uber initially
some core code goes and gets the gps api
from google maps about the user's
location sends a message to the user
through twilio
pays the driver through stripe if those
services weren't available to the people
who made uber
they wouldn't have made uber right
because they would have written their
core code on some database
and then they would have had to make a
geolocation company a telecom messaging
company
and the global payments company and they
wouldn't have done that because it's too
hard
and that's the weird scenario that a lot
of people in our industry are in
and that's the problem that oracle's and
oracle networks fix
is they provide these decentralized
services
to take um this developer ecosystem the
blockchain
and smart contract developer ecosystem
from hey
i can have a database and write some
application logic about tokenization and
voting
and private key signing all of which is
super useful and is a critical
foundation
but now if you just lay around all the
world services
whether that's market data weather data
randomness suddenly people can build
defy
fraud proof gaming fraud prove global
trade fraud proof ad networks
and and that's why this world of
decentralized services and decentralized
oracle networks
is particularly you know in my opinion
important to our industry
you